and instagram knows that there's nothing
that keeps people on the platform as
long as reels do reels just keep people
on the platform for longer and so while
instagram can say all they want that we
don't prioritize reels we don't rank
reels over other things they do they
show reels to more people they show
reels to more of your existing followers
they show your reels to more of your
non-followers people who don't know you
yet but might be perfect to follow you
uh the reach of reels compared to any
other kind of post on instagram it's
just night and day and so when i say
post more of what instagram wants
make the beast of instagram happy by
posting more reels
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres your host of this
show and here on this podcast show we're
helping you grow your influence on
youtube and then turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
online business and today we're diving
into social media yes we are instagram
teachers but we'd love to bring our
industry expert friends here to the
podcast who are growing rapidly on other
channels today it's all about instagram
but before we get into that i want to
let you know that there are still
tickets for sale for our video live
conference that is happening may 2022
and you can still lock in early bird
pricing for that conference by going to
growthvideolive.com i'll tell you more
about some of the amazing speakers who
will be at the conference this year
after this episode but let's get into
instagram today we're going to be
talking about three tips for growing on
instagram before we jump in though are
you already active on there i have just
started to come back to the platform
really getting into reels and
understanding that platform on a deeper
basis and man am i seeing growth happen
because of consistency our expert today
is brock johnson and he's going to be
sharing with you three tips for you to
be able to grow your instagram this year
now instagram is changing like crazy and
brock is bringing the latest and
greatest tips for you here on the
podcast so let's jump into today's
featured content with sean cannell and
brock johnson
welcome back to the think media podcast
i'm fired up to have brock johnson back
on the show now you may know him from
instagram he is an instagram expert he
is been on the podcast before sharing
tips of how to grow on instagram but
he's also
recently taken his youtube channel much
more seriously him and his fiancee are
growing up and van life kind of rv life
channel snowboarder we've been on the
slopes a little bit together and just an
overall cool dude
has really built a six and now seven
figure business at the young
spry age
of 24 years old 24. i'll be 25 at the
end of the month so i'm almost an old
man almost forbes 25 under 25
a list that doesn't exist but you're on
it thank you and so i i i've decided but
anyways brock um instagram i think we
know that it's a powerful place to be we
mainly help youtube creators but there's
just too much opportunity with youtube
shorts which could be repurposed onto
tick tock and instagram
we do recommend people stay focused and
not try to do too much too soon but if
you follow the think media model
eventually you've got revenue flowing
you've got maybe a team around you
virtual assistants around you editors
helping you kind of have that going on
in your business and so we are very
actively posting on instagram tick tock
um and all of the platforms but today
we're drilling in on three
rapid growth strategies for instagram
but let's start with the state of the
union for 2022. is instagram still
is there opportunity there can we grow
there what should we be aware of break
it down absolutely i mean the growth is
still there it's still absolutely
possible we're seeing accounts in every
niche everything from dog instagram
accounts to fitness instagram accounts
to uh network marketers and coaches in
every niche grow on instagram we even
just last week uh saw one of our new
accounts grow by 159 percent just based
off of the week before that it had grown
that much more in just one week
so it's absolutely still growing
platform
and what i think is really cool is their
commitment they being instagram their
commitment to creators and letting
creators drive the platform and
increasing monetization options which is
something that youtube's had for so long
and now instagram is trying to
step up to the plate so to speak when it
comes to paying creators and giving them
a way to make money on the platform and
what is the state of instagram i mean
they made that
famous headline announcement that it's
no longer a photo sharing app there's
obviously live stream there video is a
major thing
what is kind of
what instagram is now and where you see
it going in terms of what even the
platform is
yeah i i loved that that statement and
it sent shockwaves through the social
media sphere right when their ceo was
like we're not just a photo sharing app
they haven't been just a photo sharing
app since 2013 or 2012 when they first
released video onto the feed as a way to
complete with vine where's vine today
and then soon after that they introduced
stories as a way to compete with
snapchat where's snapchat today compared
to where it was five years ago so that's
not to say that instagram monopolizes
everyone and and there's no other
platform no other way to go
but instagram continues to grow and be
successful and so i think uh where they
are headed is even more short form video
i think that was the statement they were
trying to make is we're not just a photo
sharing app you can share photos but
videos stories live videos reels all of
these different vertical short form
videos are really effective on the
platform man so powerful let's get into
these tips okay so if we want to grow on
instagram from just starting into
instagram we want to expand onto another
platform tip number one is you want your
content to be shareable what does that
mean yeah shareable or share worthy it's
just worthy of your followers sharing it
to their story with their friends
tagging some of their followers in your
post because that's the ultimate way to
grow it's the online equivalent of word
of mouth
right you and i are walking around here
at social media marketing world and
you're able to introduce me to someone
else say hey this is my buddy brock and
he does this it's the same thing just
online and so there's nothing stronger
than that and i think the ultimate way
to tell if your content is shareable is
after creating it just ask yourself
would a stranger care to see this
because if a stranger would care to see
it it would be valuable to them and it
would be worth sharing strong
if a stranger doesn't care to see it if
it's you know a video of you hanging out
with sean bradley i would care to see it
but a stranger might not care to see
that wow you know what's kind of funny
is
if i think about my own behavior um
there is all kinds of instagram stuff i
dm people and we kind of dm to talk
about it on the back end so i'll send
something to like heather taurus on the
team like this is so funny or you got to
see this and it might be something funny
it might be something like that i want
to implement this is like a to-do i
might send it to like mel or something
like let's try this marketing strategy
and we have some group dms going with
this is other funny stuff between like
jordan perez and my wife and i or
whatever and so
it is interesting because it totally
makes sense that it's at that moment
that that content is being dm to
somebody else it could be spread and so
if you reverse engineer some of your own
behavior i'm curious brock is there any
kind of templates that could get us
started that you think about
like a checklist to think about okay
um how could if i'm trying to generate
an idea of my next post
that would be shareable
the things that are most shareable is if
there's any sort of news headline
trending topic so i think of youtube
like when youtube shorts first came out
that was like the big news on instagram
yeah or on youtube excuse me and if you
made an instagram post at that time
breaking down here's what youtube shorts
are here's how they work here's how you
can use them sure you're bringing that
news to people and people then want to
pass that news along and share that news
along so news any sort of insights or
things like that
and then things that are just
motivational or inspirational quotes
stories from your own personal growth or
your own experiences
those are kind of the two things that
get shared the most
number two is post what
instagram wants
what does instagram want
instagram wants people to spend time on
instagram every social media platform
wants people to spend more time on
platform top yes exactly
and instagram knows that there's nothing
that keeps people on the platform as
long as reels do reels just keep people
on the platform for longer and so while
instagram can say all they want that we
don't prioritize reels we don't rank
reels over other things they do they
show reels to more people they show
reels to more of your existing followers
they show your reels to more of your
non-followers people who don't know you
yet but might be perfect to follow you
uh the reach of reels compared to any
other kind of post on instagram it's
just night and day and so when i say
post more of what instagram wants
make the beast of instagram happy by
posting more reels yeah and you know
there's a lot of ways to do this of
course there's you got to follow brock
on instagram and we'll link them up in
the show notes and the youtube
description on the podcast you know but
um
he your way of doing reels is like being
creative and making those reels right
now my way of been doing it is thank god
we have a team and so a lot of my
content is being chopped up from a talk
or from a live stream or from a youtube
video
ben azadi in our community part of our
video ranking academy he uses repurpose
house
and repurpose house will
take your video podcast or a youtube
video you just give them a time code and
they'll put it into like a template for
you and and some of these formats work
better than others but here's what i
think i always feel guilty when i'm
around you
mainly the emotion i feel around brock
is shame honestly um but i kind of joke
but seriously because i'm like oh man
there's so much opportunity i got to get
serious about my real game but my focus
is youtube so mainly
what is being posted there is repurposed
but especially for business owners if
you're doing video on content anywhere
else you can maybe get a va have
somebody help you and it's crazy the
results we're getting because i mean
this is being repurposed and we might
get 5 000 views 4 000 views 26 000 views
11 000 views and it's it's a system
and it's leveraging reels though reels
is the content format that is crushing
for us it is a system i'm five days a
week with it and i mean you're sometimes
encouraging people to do
30 days one a day two a day even though
because reels can really get you so much
reach and let's bring it back to the why
oh that sounds like work well yeah it's
your business like work it mm-hmm and
what's on the other side new followers
leads sales yeah yeah more potential
subscribers for your youtube
and i think that there's of course a
spectrum to to reels you can make them
all original content within instagram
some people are all about tick tock um
and so they just take their tick tocks
and put them on reels something that
we're doing with that van life channel
that we started talking about is you
know our youtube videos are five eight
minutes long that they're longer reels
can only be 60 seconds so all we do is
when we finish recording our youtube
video we just turn our camera or our
phone on its side so it's now shooting
vertically and we just kind of record a
shorter version a snippeted version yeah
because it only has to be a minute so we
can really condense the content down we
can really make it short and punchy and
then like you said we have hired a
youtube manager who then edits that up
and chops it up for us and then we have
a reel that perfectly coincides with the
youtube video man so many ideas flowing
think media podcasts of course let us
know whether it's leaving a review or on
the youtube channel uh have you been
started instagram share your handle and
are you using reels definitely give us
that feedback but number three then
is post more yeah yeah and it's like the
least sexy tip but it's the ultimate way
to grow on on instagram the more you
post the more you grow this is in any
industry uh the statistics prove it it's
a perfect graph as you post more the
growth also increases um and that's
because we're all challenged by this
algorithm right every platform has an
algorithm
well when you're posting more
you don't have to stress about is the
algorithm going to show it to the right
amount of people is it going to show it
to enough people what if someone doesn't
see it when you're posting more you have
more opportunities to reach those people
to serve that audience and to grow to a
new wider audience and so i really like
to say that your focus on instagram
should be on quantity rather than
quality so we're not throwing quality
out the window i'm not telling you to
post just random you know stuff
throughout the day
but your focus is on that that quantity
because quantity breeds quality so if
you want to get better you should post
more if you want to reach more people
you should post more if you want to grow
your audience and serve more people and
connect with more people you got to be
posting more it's brilliant brock
johnson if people want to connect with
you where can they follow you online uh
myspace is always good yes instagram is
the best spot to connect with me brock
11 johnson is my instagram thank you so
much thank you well i hope that brought
you value and that you're getting
excited about growing your instagram
account as well i love hearing brock's
enthusiasm on the platform and because
of instagram he's been able to grow his
business to multiple six figures so when
you're consistent when you post where
instagram wants you to post and when
you're actually doing the things that
instagram wants you to do you can start
to see growth as well happen but here at
think media we really recommend that you
choose one primary platform and one
secondary platform and right now
instagram's hot so that might be your
secondary platform
the reason we choose to do youtube first
is because it is search based because it
is uh leverage on your time and you can
actually reach a ton of people the exact
people you want to reach with your
content on a more consistent basis but
for the secondary platform i highly
recommend instagram be the one that you
choose well i want to thank our
listeners here on the podcast for being
a part of this journey can you believe
we just hit 50 000 subscribers over on
youtube i am so blown away by the impact
that you guys are having because of this
podcast the impact you're taking to your
businesses and applying and i love being
able to read the rating and reviewing or
reading the reviews over on
apple podcast but thank you for rating
it as well i mean the five stars that
you're giving us it just warms my heart
all the time thank you so much today i
want to shout out one of our listeners
that said this is solid strategic tips
this podcast helps me build strategy and
confidence to meet my goals thanks well
thank you so much for being a part of
what we're doing here at think media
thank you for being a listener here on
the tuesday ritual that we have on the
podcast and if you didn't know over on
the youtube channel we actually post
bonus episodes and bonus trainings that
will help you grow your online business
we've covered things like how to create
small offers that can grow your business
into the six figures we've covered
things like how to dominate on facebook
and so much more so if you want to go
deeper in understanding the whole online
space our podcast channel over on
youtube is going to help you go deeper
in that but thank you so much for being
a part of what we're doing here at think
media thank you for subscribing and if
you've not already gotten your tickets
to growth video live now is the time you
can go to growthvideolive.com
and check out all of the amazing
speakers who are coming like chalene
johnson patrick betdavid gary vaynerchuk
vanessa lau jasmine star sean cannell
omar alticore heather torres and so much
more
are going to be at growth video live
2022 make sure you're in the room
because it is going to be like no other
conference you've ever been to we are
showing up to help you grow your
personal brand with video with some
incredible entrepreneurs who are doing
exactly that thanks for being a listener
here on the podcast and we'll catch you
in the next episode did you hear that
growth video live 2022 is back in person
this is your opportunity to network with
like-minded people just like you to make
friendships to make business
partnerships this is your opportunity to
get in the room you can get your ticket
now at growethvideolive.com
they're going so fast so make sure you
get your ticket right now at
growthvideolive.com
[Music]
you